Helen and Carmelo Boyle are sisters both
nurses both on strike today
I met them in October
gosh this came a couple of days ago now
but I've been working so I thought I'll
wait and then open it so I can have a
good read yeah yeah oh okay
their ballot papers had just come
through the post and they had a decision
to make are you prepared to take part in
strike action
yes it's the only way isn't it Carmel is
a union rep for the Royal College of
Nursing helping her sister make sense of
it all
a long time coming isn't it um
part of me really wants to do it another
part of me really absolutely doesn't
want to go on strike but I think it's
time isn't it yeah it is now as you say
it's a long time coming and we've been
waiting for this and we've been
talking to people about it for a long
time and now we're enough is enough
yeah history in the making
it is historic there's no doubt but it
also means Helen and Carmel and their
colleagues are away from their Wards and
away from their patients
how do how do you feel now you're here
on the picket line
[Music]
is to make the decision in the first
place to come on strike today if we
don't do something now if we don't get
the pay award that we do deserve are we
going to get more nurses are we going to
keep nurses that we've already got or
are we going to keep losing experience
there's clearly a lot of support for
these nurses you can hear it from the
motorists passing by every second but
it's also clear that these nurses are
doing this with an awful lot of
reluctance they don't want to be here
they want to be they say in the
hospitals tooting their patients but
it's also clear that the negotiations
between the government and the unions
have broken down and they're now
preparing themselves for more strikes as
the winter goes on
how sustainable is it Carmel over the
typical winter pressures that the NHS is
feeling
for nurses to continue to do this how
feasible is it that that's possible
given that the pressures that are that
are already under the pressures that
we're under are what it's reality every
single day so I know there is disruption
today but there's disruption every day
as things get canceled and moved because
there's not enough for the workforce
nurses are playing catch-up and enough
is enough
the government says it can't give the
nurses what they want but the stakes are
high in this dispute and NHS already at
Breaking Point the lives of patients
caught in the middle
Nick Martin Sky News Liverpool